[Rires]
[Musique]
nous pouvons être des super-héros dans lesquels nous vivons dans
l'état actuel où nous n'avons aucun
contrôle sur quoi que ce soit, ce sont
des moments effrayants sans précédent où
tout est hors de notre contrôle, sauf que
nous, en tant que survivants, pouvons aider, nous pouvons être
ceux qui courent vers le feu dans notre
propre combinaison de matières dangereuses construite en interne
[Musique]
vraiment important d'avoir assez de plasmon
sont des mensonges sinon nous ne pourrons pas
accorder là où cela fonctionne le mieux et
c'est pourquoi nous obtenons si des donateurs
sortent  et donner du sang, nous devons remplir notre
banque de sang avec du plasma afin que nous puissions faire
les essais de manière appropriée pour vraiment
comprendre où cela fonctionne
[Rires]
[Musique]
et leurs ego de côté et se sont regroupés
pour essayer de travailler ensemble pour le
bien commun et moi  pense qu'à la fin la
science sortira j'ai bon espoir et
j'espère que quelque chose
finira par fonctionner et ralentira le virus et
nous fera gagner du temps et finalement nous aurons
soit un vaccin soit un médicament qui
empêchera la maladie grave
[Musique]
nous  tiennent une liste courante de toutes
les études que nous pouvons trouver dans le
pays et les rendent disponibles et
agissent comme une sorte d'entremetteur entre les
instituts de recherche et les survivants pour
rendre le système plus efficace et
accélérer le processus parce que nous n'avons pas
de temps à perdre  des vies sont en jeu
[Musique]